great thank you so much and thanks to
the organizers for inviting me today I'm
going to talk about a little bit of some
of the things that we've been talking
about over the past week so far
regarding looking at the network and
looking at changes and we're going to
tie in a little bit of diffusion but you
can think about it in some ways but I'm
going to take a much higher level view
than we've been looking at today and
we're going to do this with regard to
some sort of general biological
questions but almost exactly what we
were just talking about and that was I
might want to look at relationships in a
particular species with one gene to
another gene in a different species or I
might be trying to sort of look for
changes we might be actually trying to
do exactly this where we were looking
for changes in the organism we might be
trying to look at disease models we
might be trying to understand how the
organism operates under stress so an old
school comparison of course would be
looking at just strings and as Ron said
yesterday we have much much more
information that maybe we shouldn't even
be looking at this as a network that
we've got these sort of
three-dimensional models here we've got
one one of my favorite jeans veg f1 at
Donna's too and we look at this of
course and we see that these proteins
are actually 3d models they physically
interact and there might be more subtle
interactions to we might be looking at a
genetic interaction where it might be
positive or negative depending on it and
of course we're going to look at this as
if it's a network so we are going to
sort of take a slice of this we're going
to do an abstraction so a high level
view of just jeans as interactions and
I'll define for each of the particular
applications what kind of interaction
I'm talking about but think dots in line
so each of the nodes will be some
protein in each will be some kind of
interaction and what we want to address
here is we want to look at this as a
global scale on that particular graph we
want to see what is actually changed so
did it did I lose an interaction across
some sort of evolution or did I lose an
interaction because of a stress or maybe
I've gained an additional node or maybe
a whole entire piece of sort of the
network is sort of drifting away in some
sense and what we've sort of done is we
said well we actually know something
more than that we have reference points
and so with regard to this we said let's
stop for a second and say we
have known nodes where we might know
some information can we leverage that
those particular nodes that we have some
information and in some sense seed is it
were a matching between the graphs so
that we could look for these individual
changes so here we might know something
to say we've got the purple node and we
know that for instance this is something
that's conserved if I were doing
something like an alignment it might be
a homologue if I were doing something
where I were interested in something
around cancer it might be a particular
cancer gene that we know is in a
different few different types of cancer
and what we're going to do is we're
going to sort of just because diffusion
seems to be the sort of topic or the
underlying thing here is we might
actually pick our favorite distance
metric and we're going to see that we're
going to use only diffusion and what
we're going to do is we're going to sort
of look at the graph we're going to real
able it if you will with regard to these
fixed sort of genes that we know some
information about and so what I could do
here is if you look on the two gray
nodes I could actually sort of create a
vector if you will in this in this sort
of graph space that would say I'm one
away from the purple so we let the
purple be dimensioned one we let the I
guess looking at this we let the
yellowish sort of be dimensioned two and
our turquoise sort of dimension 3 and
then we can label the nodes specifically
to sort of recover in some sense where
they are in the network now of course I
can't having been a theorist in my
former life and being in this particular
building we might ask ourselves what it
is about sort of graphs or networks to
be able to sort of label them can we
uniquely recover the entire network
using a few sort of labelings this has
been done before I'll just say this has
been done before and in kind of an
interesting example and that is the
pioneer plaque so when we sent out this
sort of into space this particular
pioneer plaque we wanted to tell
everyone where we were whether this is
good or bad or whatever your beliefs are
here they did so by sort of 14 pulsars
and the pulsars had a unique sort of
signature for each one of these things
and what we did is we told everyone
where the Sun was with regard to these
14 pulsars with the idea that people
could find us so this sort of idea of
finding individual nodes from a mapping
from a reference
point map of course has been around for
quite some time so the idea here of
course is we want to create if you like
a new representation Lenora sort of
mentioned during the talk we were
looking at these diffusion metrics and
we said well we can think about this is
an entire embedding right if I'm going
to let diffusion process walk completely
over the graph that in some sense what
I'm looking at as an entire embedding of
the graph with regard to some distance
well you can think about that we're
doing is we're trying to reduce that
dimension we're going to try to actually
look at this in a sort of smaller scale
so what we're going to do for each of
these applications we're going to select
some landmarks these landmarks of course
hopefully have some kind of biological
meaning but we'll come back to sort of
what they might be theoretical in a
minute we're going to then label the
graph whatever your favorite distance
metric is the first thing we should ask
is is this sort of in some sense
feasible being a former complexity
theorist and the answer is of course no
this is this is actually the metric
dimension of a graph so this is somewhat
well studied inside of theory I didn't
know about it when we first came up with
it so shame on me being a complexity
theorist of my former life and it turns
out that the metric dimension of the
graph is just looking and asking the
question if I were going to give you a
subset of the vertices of the graph how
many would I need to be able to uniquely
identify the rest of the graph and here
of course the distance is just the hop
just the next hop distance and so if we
look at this particular example one of
my little favorite little graphs is we
need to for this graph if you look
carefully here we go through we label it
by the first one it's at dimension zero
with three away from the other landmark
so on and so forth and then of course
3041 if I try to do this with one node
it's not going to work and in some sense
what's going to happen is there's a
symmetry along the triangle here but I
don't want you to sort of be confused
with just symmetries it's not this is a
rigid graph so they're in there are no
trivial there's only one automorphism
the autumn or some fizz immed itself and
so this isn't necessarily a
distinguishing number so people have
looked at sort of the distinguishing
number to break automorphisms it's
related you would need actually the
distinguishing number plus additional
things so it's strictly bigger than the
distinguishing number this uh this is
also in a proximal so this means that
there's no
approximation scheme whatsoever in fact
it's worse than that so since we're in
this building it's actually W to
complete which means it it doesn't
actually work even with the sort of
factor we can't do this as a sort of
constant factor in any way shape or form
so no constant factor it's not fixed
parameter tractable we can't really get
at this so you might say is all lost
well again we're trying to address this
with biology so we have information we
can just use what we have we might hope
that we're getting an approximation or
some reasonable amount of the network
but we can still try so for instance we
select the landmarks we pick our
distance again operated just for what we
might be interested in so it might be a
diffusion process we're going to label
it and then in some sense this really is
we've been talking about an embedding
into the metric space so here if you
like this in some sense this node B
becomes an axis and really I'm measuring
everyone's distance against that access
to that particular node the inode is now
another axis and I'm measuring everyone
against that distance now this is not in
any way shape or form going to be two
dimensions we're going to be working in
things like 200 to 500
now the big claim here is that this is
going to allow us to be able to make
comparisons so if I take one particular
graph see the graph on the top was
embedded in this space so it's here in
all red nodes I take a second graph here
in the bottom with all blue notes and
the idea is that I can somehow overlay
the two particular embeddings in some
reasonable way once we do that we might
be able to make comparisons across the
networks in this new space now I want to
point out that making comparisons in
this new space might be a different
distance metric to be able to sort of
cluster these particular things and i'll
talk more about that in a minute I know
first do a quick application that's been
very well studied here by many people in
the room to the network alignment
problem so here I might be working in a
species a mouse and I want to make
comparisons sort of on a global scale to
the human network and I want to look in
this case I want to look for some
similarities in some sense what are the
sort of things that have been preserved
there's a ton of work by many of the
people that are in the room here
throughout the entire time so there's
many more that I haven't even listed
some new stuff that we heard about from
Natasha earlier this week as well so
again what are we solving with the
network alignment we're just trying to
make matches right so I might I might
have one gene and I just want to point
out these things might actually be
mapping to to just as we had sort of
heard we might have one particular gene
that's either co-evolved or I've got two
two genes that I want to map it to maybe
I'm mapping to 22 so there are lots of
genes that shouldn't be matched there's
lots that should again this is another
one of these NP complete problems
because we're related to sort of sub
graph isomorphism so we're actually
harder than just sort of graph
isomorphism I did here in a one theory
paper that Bob I said that the key to
solving graph isomorphism was the metric
dimension the citation was personal
communication so unfortunately I don't
have the paper some of this with
alignment the results were presented
last year at is mb and the ideas we
looked at this we named it as ben says
you should always name it that'll help
things so we named it sort of course
alignment again we're not looking
necessarily at the same level where
people have been looking at like the
graphite degree work where you might be
trying to make comparisons here we're
trying to
on a local scale we're trying to look on
a much broader scale and then apply it
perhaps to something that does like
Magnus a where you would actually go
through and optimize for local
conditions we're trying to look for just
functional matches we're not going to
use sequence so there's something that I
want to sort of say right out we're not
going to actually use sequence in any
way shape or form many of the previous
work it's particularly I so rank and hub
a line use a lot of sequence to
influence how matches are made we're
going to use structure alone now you
might argue wait Ben you're using a
little bit of this because you're going
to use some homologs and that's true
we're going to use we're going to sort
of seed it using a little bit of
sequence and then ignore sequence from
there on up and so just as I alluded to
when we do this we're going to actually
do alignment biology told us something
with regard to who should be the special
nodes here we're going to use homologs
and I'm hoping row dead we'll ask the
exact same question that he asked
earlier which is we did the same thing
we're going to throw out any homologs
that actually are multiple maps we're
going to sort of avoid them completely
so we are going to do one-to-one
mappings only we take them from homology
and we're just going to sort of say
that's our sort of seated network for
this particular problem
in our preliminary results we actually
used ESD again that Lenore had talked
about where we're using a diffusion
distance we're going to downplay hubs
and sort of here again just a reminder
for everyone that saw it it's you can
think about it is i would say who do you
want to set up on a date you want to set
up a and B or do you want to set up C
and D and the idea is most likely a and
B because there's a lot of interactions
of low degree as opposed to sort of one
that's sitting in the center I do want
to also say that we're looking at this
it's not required that we use DSD in
fact in fact actually we've been
studying the human network and we're
realizing that some of the diffusion
techniques that's from the Raphael lab
are actually a little bit better or
seemed to correspond closer to things
like Resnick scores so here we're
looking at maximum information content
using go and so the using a sort of
labeling somehow it does seem to be that
some of the heat things work better on
the human network but DSD outperforms on
the yeast network I point this out
because this technique does not require
that you use the same metric on the same
network you could pick your favorite
network your favorite functional sort of
measurement on yeast then pick your
favorite functional measurement on human
and then actually embed them into this
space and make a comparison across the
space so again we're going to sort of
take the two networks we're going to
line them and ideally what we'd want to
do is sort of find a nice clustering
metric so we'd want to sort of find a
way to sort of cluster these again for
preliminary results I'm going to sort of
force things to make one to one matches
so for now think i could cluster right
now just to make an easier i'm going to
do a sort of one-to-one matching and
sort of the best and so again how do we
do that we're doing a similar across
species and this picture is a little bit
of a misnomer and part of if you think
about it carefully I might have the
yeast network and I've got maybe five
hundred landmarks and I compare it with
500 human landmarks but the network
sizes are so different that actually the
scale on this is very different so when
I say I'm going to align these and
suddenly I'm going to get blue dots near
red dots that's it's a little bit of a
misnomer with this picture
we're really going to do is we're going
to take all of them in one network all
of the other network now remember each
one of the dots is in like a 500
dimensional space so then I'm going to
take something to be able to sort of
compare or reduce that yet again and
what we did is we either do l1 norm if
you're about the same size so for
comparing the same network to this on
different network under stress we might
do something like l1 norm if you're
going to take the yeast network or the
mouse network and compare it to humans
you would do something like a cosine
similarity am I sort of at least in the
right direction in this
multi-dimensional space so think cosine
similarity for any time I'm using
species that are very very far apart
think l1 norm if I'm doing something
that where I know the number of nodes is
exactly the same good and again this is
these are fake numbers here but what
that's going to do is it's going to give
me an all against all matrix in some
sense a sort of similarity matrix for
each one of these particular genes and
then I could do something like a
Hungarian algorithm or something more
sophisticated like cluster so again
preliminary results the ppi network so
unfortunately flies sitting right there
in the middle Natasha I apologize I had
no idea the but apparently now I have a
new yeast yeast network that I can't
wait to try out too so that's pretty
exciting just we use string a little bit
older version of this just to give you
some ideas the human network is about
14,000 the yeast there is going to be
5,000 now anybody that's a gene counter
is going to realize that these are a
little bit lower numbers that's because
we take the largest connected component
and in fact you should probably actually
take the two core as well to get better
results with regard to diffusion the two
cores of course going to remove all of
those sort of dangling tails Donna sort
of mentioned this in her talk if you've
got a dangling tail you can't make a
comparison to another one that's an
automorphism automatically right so all
of those the other thing you might think
of as disconnected components are always
going to connect to other disconnected
components so the reason we don't do it
is DSD these diffusion techniques can't
be computed is the real reason but you
can think that I can't break those
automorphisms as well we're going to use
go in terms of our
functional comparisons test it sort of
we wanted to know does this in some
sense again these diffusion techniques
did they sort of work with perturb
network so can I start with a ground
truth and so we created sort of tests
with ground truth and the way that we
did this is we took the mouse network we
picked the mouse Network cuz we want to
pick one that's sort of big in some
sense we took it we cloned it and then
we perturbed a copy we did this multiple
times we chose the landmarks at random
because i'm using the same particular
network i can choose the sort of
homologs or preserve things we actually
ran tests on degree whether you were a
high between the scores high degree
random was best to be perfectly honest i
hypothesized that this is because
randomly is in some sense getting a
better sort of closer approximation to
this actual metric dimension of the
graph and you can think about it is it's
just going to be spread out there going
to be sort of spread out in such a way
that will do better in some ways we use
the Hungarian just to be able to create
a perfect matching and then we go
through and take a look at how it did
again thin what we do we did a
perturbation where we thin the network
so here we're just going to sort of
assign probabilities to every note edge
in the graph we're going to move
everyone underneath that threshold so we
can sort of do different levels of sort
of thin across this similarly we did a
rewire here we're going to sort of pick
it up and move it at random so if you're
below the threshold I'm going to sort of
pick an end at random and I'm going to
sort of force you to join someone new
and we force you to join somebody new
you don't necessarily sort of land back
on yourself assigned them randomly so
I'm just gonna go ahead and sign it
randomly across the edges no and it's
just there's no no interesting
distribution at all
and then scramble we picked it up and we
sort of completely said you got to go
somewhere else we move the edge again
not a rewire but you said you've got to
go find somewhere else to actually do
this and so how did we do we ran it all
the way to the end just to sort of see
how it is and you can see pretty much we
drop off pretty quickly as just as does
everyone else I want to do point out to
a lot of the other sort of competing
ones they're meant to be done with
sequins or with additional information
this is structure only so these are not
necessarily the way that you would run
these other competitors we're looking at
just structure on itself and so what we
see with using diffusion is in fact you
do get a sort of break or a slow sort of
curve here and one of the reasons I
think that's possible again is because
diffusion is sort of more robust in some
sense to noise so we see for each of the
sort of tests that we're sort of in some
ways sort of tailing off a little bit
slower I do want to point out since this
shows up in reviewers all the time that
you do care about this huge amounts of
perturbation you might say why would you
destroy a network to fifty percent
because you must be at noise I will of
course remind everyone there are five
thousand inside of mice there are 15,000
inside of humans the networks are more
than fifty percent different so we do
need to find a sort of robust technique
to sort of find at least the course
alignment and then maybe do a finer
granularity so that's that's my is one
of my personal beliefs what happens with
no ground truth so here we looked at
this and we said we want to actually do
this on real networks so we tested it
against all of the networks we're going
to do a measure of performance here with
biological similarity there are
obviously structural similarities that
many of the people have come up with in
the room s3 and ICS for instance we
looked at biological and functional
similarity partly because we don't make
good matches at a local level so we will
not actually get good scores for ICS or
s3 what we get is something that's much
more functional so again homologs are my
landmarks we did three types of
validation techniques we did the
functional consistency here we're
looking at do I match a particular go
term we did the jacquard
so here we're going to actually look
across and sort of see the number in
some sense or the amount of sort of
annotation that matches and then we did
a kind of cross validation and again
this time we did a Hungarian algorithm
although you could use and probably
should use something more sophisticated
and we tested this against and we do
pretty well so we're compared to again
hub a line and magna and DS we're doing
just as well sometimes a little bit
better on human and mouse and yeast to
human but this is a shared go term so I
do want to say this means that there
exists a go term this go term could be
biological process so in some sense you
know saying I've got seventy percent
match this could be at a very very high
level the so so jacquard go is a much
sort of better way to sort of think
about this and then you can see it hub a
line actually does quite well how the
line uses a lot of sequence again so
there is going to be sort of a bias here
and then we're we're on standard for
these things may be a little bit better
on each of them one of the things I
think though that's more interesting is
we take now and try to do a cross
validation on homologs and hear what I
do is I take fifty percent of my
landmarks and I make that the target set
the other fifty percent be my our my
anchors so I take all of the sort of
homologs that I have and I hide half of
them and we just ask can you recover
them to what degree can you actually
cover recover them we're now again this
isn't cluster level these are the
perfect matches with the perfect match
do I get it back so it's pretty it's
pretty strict and we see we do quite
well on actually unfortunately some of
the fly but we do well on sort of worm
and yeast here where these things are a
little bit less I so rank actually does
well on Mouse and hub a line does very
well on the mouse to human so we're
doing quite well when we ask for these
exact matches and again this is the
Hungarian so we might be able to recover
this when we do something more
sophisticated at a group level
then we actually sort of said well we
are we don't use sequence so we didn't
we didn't test the sort of validate with
sequins but what we said is do we
actually get to find sort of a novel
match in some sense where I might make a
functional match because if this is
truly a functional embedding can I make
a functional match and so what we did is
we sort of just calculated the Resnick
score the Resnick score again is the
maximum information content so here I'm
going to actually look at the annotation
across the corpus I'm going to look at
how detailed in some sense is the
measurement I have how detailed your
annotation is not do we match on
biological process do we match on
something that's very specific and we
just ranked them we just found our sort
of top 10 in some sense and what we
found is we found homologs so this sort
of top three in terms of our score were
in fact homologs that weren't part of my
system things that I didn't know about
so these aren't landmarks these are just
ones that I didn't do there may be were
the ones I threw out because they might
have a multiple match but then what we
looked at is we had high functional
scores and loeb last bit scores with
long sequence length so here we've got
these things that aren't necessarily
based on sequence but do seem to be
related in function and then we went
back and sort of said all right let's
actually look all of these up and we saw
things where we had similar arrangements
similar structure coordinators
regulators things that have been known
to be biological or have a biological
citation that says these things look
like they are the same so we were quite
pleased with that now we did this with
the idea that we wanted to make
comparisons but we also said we'll wait
can we actually look at this and try to
do differences now here I might be the
exact same network the exact same number
of nodes but I now want to know what
look at the amount of rewiring that's
been going on again at this sort of
global scale in the network so here it's
a little bit different we calculate the
same score we'll use an l1 norm because
i actually have exactly the same scale
so l1 will work just as well as sort of
l2 or even a cosine similarity we
actually then only care about the
diagonal because the idea here is my
network is exactly the same my node
matching is known it's the same network
I know what the note is
before I want to know has it sort of
moved or has its pattern sort of shifted
in the network so now I care only about
the diagonal and again I'm looking at
how much does it changed against the
target set we did this is very
preliminary as in the the last couple of
weeks we looked at this in two different
sort of things the the first one was we
looked at genetic interactions the
krogan lab had to the original sort of I
guess wild type of the genetic
interactions and now the mms damaged and
that they looked at this and they said
well what are the rewire things that
have sort of happened when I do sort of
DNA damage and what we looked at is two
different types of landmarks high degree
and static nodes we use positive and
negative so as Anastasia was telling us
before we should separate those things
out to get a better signal right now we
wanted a little bit bigger network so we
dump them all in together we used ESD as
a distance and what we found when we
sort of looked at the sort of top things
that percolated all the way to the top
the most sort of change in the network
were in fact reported as mms repair the
highest in both static in this was
actually a transport gene and the idea
it so this was actually an undergraduate
that did this work and she ran to her
biologist professor and said why is this
happening and she correctly are sort of
hypothesized that of course the
transport is going to clean out the cell
so if you damage it with DNA you're
going to see this sort of a signal from
a transport because of sort of repairing
or cleaning the cell this also actually
was great that this undergrad ran and
did this because what she did is she
found a gene that the Herr professor was
interested in that had already been
looking at this with regard to mms so
this is now in the wet lab this past
year to sort of test is it in fact sort
of something that we should be caring
about with this mms repair so we're a
little bit lucky just because the
undergrad went and asked questions and
another sort of network again looking at
the sort of differential expression that
we've been thinking about and this is
pretty preliminary work as well is a
co-expression network here we're looking
at breast cancer we're looking at sort
of the estrogen receptor sort of whether
you're up regulator downregulated this
is work of one of my seniors that's
graduating this year and what he did is
he sort of collected expression networks
from a couple different experiments
and he sort of used the standard
technique to sort of transform it into a
network what we did is we actually sort
of rather than cutting off that network
we let everyone sort of vote on their
edge we let that sort of probability or
confidence of that edge we gave it a
wait we take the negative log that sort
of in some sense translate it to a
distance the landmarks we used were
up-regulated and down-regulated this was
just from the broad and then since this
distance is a weighted network we
actually use shortest paths so we looked
at sort of shortest paths across this
and then we did a cross validation test
and over a thousand runs we hide half of
these sort of 48 480 implicated genes
and the other half are sort of way far
up regulated or much higher sort of
scores than we'd expect and then we did
random landmarks for thirty percent of
the genes just to sort of in some sense
for 80 s not very big we think the
metric dimension of humans is probably
around 800 actually from our tests on
that network it looks like about 800 is
about our metric dimension so they took
we took thirty percent of them and we
saw that the up and down regulated were
consistently higher and this time we use
the cosine similarity for that one and
with that I'm just going to sort of go
through and thank all of my co-authors
this is actually a work of tons of
undergrads my cup my collaborator Marco
Vela at BU and the rest are undergrads
in bar freed is just graduated he's at
Harvard Medical Tony Quneitra who's also
worked with Ben Raphael graduated last
year he's going to start at the
University of Washington in September
Jennifer and Hammel men who did a lot of
the gene interaction networks is leaving
me for MIT next year Thomas is going to
join been at Brown in the fall and taher
is actually going to johns hopkins he's
also senior so these are the results of
many different senior theses so with
that thank you very much
some of cosine cosine yeah yeah so um
we're like the question so leave the
netbooks are not the same size doesn't
matter it is not so much we did notice
that the cosine seem to be performing a
little bit better on the the ER plus and
er- networks so we were using that so
we've been defaulting to sort of cosine
in some sense but I don't think that
there's a strong difference between them
to be perfectly honest I think there's
more work to do though and the way that
we should think about this is um let's
say that let let's say that you and I
are sort of close to a particular
homologue that's really interesting but
both of us being far away from a
homologue that's not as much information
right so my belief is that probably we
could find a bit vector sort of somehow
use a bit vector carefully in some sense
and then actually get better than both
of them thank you yeah please su now you
have small on that one you have become
network and somehow I think underlying
philosophy on the cosine that's
appealing yes and this is absolutely not
true yes yes so I think I think actually
what we should do is a much more sort of
careful in some sense you could actually
imagine waiting it right so these
landmarks perhaps maybe if you were
doing something that you were interested
in you'd wait a landmark more so the
fact that we were sort of closed on a
particular to homologs might sort of
blow out the whole entire score and say
okay that's it they should be in the
same cluster so I can see a situation
where you might even you might wait the
landmarks differently because of what
you would be interested in and far it
doesn't mean anything both of us being
far mean it there doesn't seem to be
sort of anything interesting with that
so I think cosine is our sort of first
attempt to try to get it this sort of
scale that we tried l1 and it didn't
work at all right on the human network
because it's just the just you're blown
away with these big difference is that
mean absolutely nothing so we're at
least said okay cosine might get us in
the angle but as you say they're not
uniformly different right there morph
together
so I think I think a bit vector
technique of some sort that we carefully
apply would be best oh yes please yeah
seems like you want to have as many
landmarks you want yes yes network's if
you have a gene that's disconnected in
one but connected in the other it's gone
it's gone all games are off this is an
artifact by using the diffusion pieces
because there's no way for so
essentially all of the diffusion
techniques that I do so one thing that's
great is well it's not fast but the
technique to calculate this is n cubed
so it is a couple hours in some sense as
opposed to sort of you know much much
longer time so i can calculate and do
this sort of in a couple hours even for
sort of humans and so but what I can't
do is I can't do anything with a
disconnected network just because
there's no inverse for the graph just be
your simulation experiment showed how to
perform straws with that yeah yeah put
that aside actual Anderson that he has
no networks that you know
so the so in so inter in terms of the
ones that actually a very good question
so the question is is in some sense you
see as we perturb this off these
networks are actually more than fifty
percent different so how does that sort
of relate in some ways and I think again
what you could do is something like and
I'm going to look right you could do
something interesting like take Magna
where magnetic will optimize on
particularly what you're interested in
you would take our sort of technique and
say you want sort of a course alignment
in some ways will get sort of just down
to the region level where these might be
functionally interesting but then you
get locally to try to sort of make a
better alignment what I would actually
argue is in some ways we want to sort of
get at a sort of course sweet first
because we're doing something global and
then do something interesting sort of
that is even better studied yes please
so faster in 20 seconds so my questions
/ comments just one thing is it's really
fair to compare raw scores of these
different methods given that they are
all producing different output types
such as 1 to 10 minutes yeah absolutely
so their spores absolutely what we did
for the structural part so looking at
the sort of perturbation test right and
as I said quickly like this isn't a fair
comparison because what I did is I
stripped away everything right so other
techniques are going to sort of find and
make more sophisticated matches I forced
everyone to do Hungarian and then I use
just that sort of matric for the idea of
sort of saying what similarity matrix
are we looking at but I make no sort of
make no comments about sort of you know
not you know that it works better than
magna or at all because it's not we're
not trying to in some sense solve the
same problem in fact I look at sort of a
candle a sort of precursor right so
where you might actually then sort of
use something that would optimize around
a sort of local piece so it's not a fair
comparison at all
yeah yeah we should work together okay
thank you thank you thank you